watson vielleicht möchte ihre majestät
etwas tee aber natürlich mister roms das
empire ist holmes und watson auf den ich
mit großer neugierde mich gefreut habe
auf der ich wirklich gespannt war
vielleicht doch eher eine enttäuschung
im buckingham palace
lösen sie diesen fall in vier tagen oder
ich töte die kündigung unterschrieben
professor james nun hat die sherlock
holmes und dr boxen sind eines der
bekanntesten männerpaare der geschichte
seit vielen generationen werden die
erzählungen von kurras akte gelesen und
es gibt ja auch schon zahlreiche
verfilmungen von kriminalfällen die
sherlock holmes gelöst hat und der
unterstützung und vor allem auch unter
buchführung von doktor watson die neue
amerikanische komödie holmes und watson
ist nur ein weiterer versuch dieser der
gruppendynamik oder der fahrdynamik
dieser beiden männer komischen facetten
abzugewinnen offenheit würde kann sich
niemand wird je bereut 1 verschickt will
ferrell und john o'reilly sind zwei
bestens bewährte erprobte amerikanische
komödianten starschauspieler und im
grunde versucht holmes und watson vor
allem aus diesem duo eine menge
herauszuholen fragen sie danach
architekt
rsn das die kommune kommt so richtig ins
laufen
viele der gags sind auch vielleicht ein
bisschen zu offensichtlich oder ein
bisschen zu wenig durchdacht oder im
magen vielleicht auch so ein bisschen an
intellektueller präzision
trotzdem ist es interessant sich diesen
film anzuschauen denn er zeigt uns ein
bisschen über bestimmte
weichenstellungen in der amerikanischen
komödien landschaft das schade der
amerikanischen filmkomödie hat er ja
zuletzt eine fast zwanzigjährige
hochkonjunktur es gab zahlreiche
meisterwerke und will ferrell und john
o'reilly wanner nicht wenige von diesen
beteiligen das ist mein arbeitszimmer
und mein bidla buh und das ist die große
regeln ausfassen nie niemals dieses
schlagzeug an verstanden
trotzdem ist das eine interessante
komödie die man sich vielleicht eher zu
studienzwecken anschauen wird als
unwirklich befreit und lauthals und auf
hohem niveau los zu lachen denn so viel
zu lachen gibt es leider nicht aber
warum sind warzen ist trotzdem ein
schritt in der amerikanischen komödie
der mann vielleicht doch nicht was heute
wie ich schieße sie und bin gleichzeitig
teilen davon dass man am attraktivsten
auf fotografien ist wenn man die
lippenstift und aussieht wie ein kleines
pelziges schnabeltier haben hier genug
also vielleicht sollten wir ans fenster
kinder ist das nicht viel besser